all right let's get this [ __ ] rolling
are we wrong idiot headphones if you
want uh you don't need to take your
Wareham you don't need him okay you're
gonna mess up his hair yeah you don't
wanna mess I'm not gonna be able I was a
joke all right so this podcast is a very
rare podcast extremely [ __ ] rare
today's special guest is Jake James
legend Pinellas County and his brother
Luke James also a legend yeah
our mom had two boys that were all over
TV TV I was on TV for three days about
you it's just like a solid day on day
news 9 so is a classic though Jake for
everybody out there who's not from this
area who may not know who you are give
us like just introduce yourself this
isn't local no it's not yeah it's local
to all just give me the elevator pitch
of who Jake Jamie it's a complicated and
long story he's never been in an
elevator so he's gonna have a hard time
yeah but on escalator one of those fast
walking things in the airport I would
call those that's a fast walk inside
walk oh it's like it's like a flat
escalator I like it yeah called a moving
Road that you can walk on all right like
you don't know who you are
does anybody know not really the sort of
man so kind of trying to figure it out
yeah well that's good I've just done a
lot of dumb [ __ ] like when you're a
little kid where you touch the stove you
know it's hot yeah I pretty much do that
with every aspect of my life just touch
yeah forget about it and do it the same
thing the next thing everybody doesn't
touch it he just like puts his face on
it
just like it's pretty much it's like ooh
like that me summed up real quick is I'm
either
not doing it or I'm all the way [ __ ]
in deal all in or all out yeah there's
no you would look her the same in that
aspect yeah for sure is that is that
like an up Britain is that like
something that was hardwired into you
guys as young kids I think we get it
from our mom totally but dad - yeah but
they they're extreme well they could
handle it better than well I could
because like you look right now how Luke
looked like eight years ago I know that
skinny eh yeah mmm good the protein I
think I think you're taken like the
racing for steroids straight in the ass
to the shirt
what's the shirt say Oh sworn to fun
load and none that it's a motto from one
of my good buddies dads that just passed
away okay yeah this is gnarly biker dude
dings oh [ __ ] very much like [ __ ]
everybody you know I like that dude yeah
if it aint fun [ __ ] go home right
don't do it cuz that's not fun yeah he
made it right yeah yeah okay the shirt
yeah I just been making shitty shirts
with the final iron-on letters okay
I was uh thought it was gonna start
Empire just like every just like the
Mountain Dew thing yeah I thought they
were gonna kick Dale jr. off and put me
on Mountain Dew but you mean what
Mountain Dew thing oh when we shotgun
okay yeah yeah yeah making sure so I
know you have a mountain dew tattoo also
right we got a whole backstory to the
mountain dew thing you can't just say it
nobody knows yeah give us a introduce to
all the stories Mountain Dew okay so the
Mountain Dew things started I don't know
how that started was that your idea or
my idea it was someone's idea I'm not
gonna know you wanted me to you wanted
me to do a suicide like you know near a
kid yet you hit the fountain you get all
the sodas a little bit of soda Luke
wanted me to
you like a 12-pack of every different
soda okay like how fast I could do it
yeah but then I started reading about
all those people dying from like
chugging water so my Luke I might die
dude so he was like all right let's just
do six tall boys at Mountain Dew which
was almost a gallon I really didn't do
the math but it sounded better than 12
[Music]
six tall boys twelve twelve dues but
they don't have a conversion like how
many tall boys are in a gallon well
there's 128 ounces in a gallon 16-ounce
16.9 16 - saying the cans of liquid
death 96 that was 96 ounces of Mountain
Dew 128 ounces is a gallon and you chug
the whole thing don't ask how I know
that though yeah it's on [ __ ] it's on
it's on the Frick YouTube channel yeah
it's been on there for like five years I
think I got like 150 views I thought I
was gonna get out and be a superstar but
we're literally timed it and it was how
long I think it was a minute and three
seconds minute and three seconds six
tall boy - shotgun six tall boy Mountain
Dews so bad okay so I was with a CodeRed
or regular do their a regular yeah we
don't [ __ ] with that Code Red okay okay
see the real do Baja blast or get the
[ __ ] out yeah don't hit me with that
diet yeah oh that was funny too because
I was cooking at this shitty restaurant
on the beach it was tought it was like
dollar taco day so I'm just like jamming
tacos well cooking all day and so we uh
we shotgun to all six of the do's and I
was like I just started puking right so
I'm throwing up Mountain Dew throwing up
mountain Dew and then I hit the tacos
and I was like alright I'm good so bring
up a little bit from the dues no I
pretty much got them all out
really yeah but I didn't drink Mountain
Dew for like probably like a year you
should show us the Mountain Dew tattoo
oh the whole team put up to the mic get
some more Mountain Dew that
I got that right there because I always
see guys getting tattoos of like guns in
their waistband
that's so funny we were just talking
about you to put these floors and had
that nice oh my god it's pretty stupid
still makes no sense lamest tattoos so
I'm like I want to get a [ __ ] kata
Mountain Dew in my waistband very much
like a [ __ ] you oh my gosh I was gonna
ask you uh just gonna ask a prison
question but then I realized we didn't
even like introduce that whole story yet
yeah that's why yeah go ahead you've
been to prison how long were you
imprisoned for I did total as six years
I got a seven year sentence Florida you
have to do 85% of your time so I ended
up doing like give or take a couple days
six years holy [ __ ] yeah and what did
you go in for uh armed burglary armed
robbery possession of cocaine possession
of oxycodone Wow well that's a that's a
tongue twister I think that was it yeah
that's a lot it sounds a lot worse than
it is yeah do you want to give some
backstory to the lead up yeah let it rip
oh yes how do you get arrested for well
you mean before he gets a rest
how was the how is this monster born
okay so I I was kind of late doing drugs
I guess as a kid I was probably mostly
16 I tried coke for the first time at 16
but I didn't try nothing I didn't do it
like a year - after that I didn't touch
it
okay but uh but I should have known that
first time when I did it I shouldn't
have done it anymore
right cuz it's like that's all you want
kind of deal yeah I just got a super
addictive personality kind of deal just
kind of take off with it
so you're 18 16 - 18 years old yeah but
the people out that people I ran with
was kind of they were way earlier than
me yeah I know and I would always say no
and then yeah I'm just kind of started
doing it and you know everybody says
like Oh
drugs but it's really like you're doing
them and kind of get them half-price
because you're selling if you Hetal in a
little like that making your stash
cheaper yeah well I wasn't in sight Wow
how do you know so much about this yeah
so um when I was I don't know [ __ ]
how old I was
that's kind of a blur back then but I
got a hookup with a book that had a
bunch of [ __ ] like vicodin and [ __ ]
like that and I was selling those and
then I started like you were selling
vicodins yeah so I didn't I was actually
selling them then wasn't really doing
them and didn't smoke weed they didn't
really like going out to bars drinking
yeah and then I started trying the pills
and it's like all this feels [ __ ]
great
yeah so you pop him every day and then I
didn't have him one day and I was
talking to somebody and they're like oh
you're dope sick I'm like well like a
junkie like it like doing heroin or
something random dude I was probably
although the guy I knew okay that would
that does him too and then uh I don't
even know how old I was then I was
probably I was probably like 18
somewhere in there yeah so then it just
kind of spiraled from there just started
doing heart like just higher dose ones
and with all the pill mills shit's
around here too
oh my god so it was so easy man like
totally out of control
right that was an epidemic time in
Florida first yeah rips a pill you know
these doctors man and there's there's
[ __ ] a hundred people outside waiting
right inside they can't fit no more
people in there and it's all cash and
yeah what I mean dude it's it's still
like that though I mean my wife had to
just go to the doctor and they were like
trying to give prescribe her vicodin Oh
like no I really don't want it I don't
need it I'm fine I can get she's like no
no you need it you need it they ended up
like forcing and giving the forcing her
a bottle of vicodin yeah yeah no but
these third way yeah yeah I mean they
get like their incentive like I gotta
tell him if something I'm like don't
give it to me I can't do it yeah you
know what I mean because I don't even I
don't even really I don't want
so how easy was it to get it like what
is always like well I had um when I was
15 I had screws my hips hips are all
[ __ ] up so I had x-rays and I would
just pretty much take him in there and
if I didn't have the x-rays I knew what
to tell them so they kind of know you're
not a cop or something like that I guess
yeah so we would hit like probably like
five or six of different ones a month
and I mean and you're getting [ __ ] no
we're [ __ ] put down a [ __ ]
elephant yeah and then mob like [ __ ]
you're not like oh I got a call to let
me get some of that promethazine yeah
yeah anything you wanted you just tell
me like oh I can't I can't concentrate
[Laughter]